[Music]
we're always accustomed to thinking of
inheritance as what happens in terms of
the nuclear genome that we inherit from
our mother and the nuclear genome that
we inherit from our father but what you
will see is that with mitochondria the
particular complement that is inherited
from your mother can be quite different
depending on the egg that is fertilized
so if we have a primordial egg cell and
here we have the nucleus of the egg cell
this particular egg may have let's say
three mitochondria in pink that carry
some sort of defect in their
mitochondrial genomes and then it may
have let's say six the equivalent of six
mitochondria that are perfectly healthy
what happens is in the process of
differentiation of maturation of eggs
when this undergoes cell division and
you end up with let's say two eggs you
can have a situation
where you have a distribution of
mitochondria where in this case the cell
on the right only received one of the
diseased mitochondria
while the cell on the left actually
received two what this means is that the
quantity the relative ratio of normal to
defective mitochondria is quite
different if you compare these two egg
cells so what this means is that
depending on which one is fertilized the
resulting embryo may have either a
significantly greater number of diseased
mitochondria or defective mitochondria
versus less and so this actually helps
determine whether or not the individual
in question
you know the resulting child that is
produced from that egg whether or not
that child will express the disease or
not express the disease or if it does
express the disease how severely
affected they might be by the
mitochondrial disease so what this means
is that mitochondria and their
distribution their ratio in a particular
egg cell in one woman can be quite
variable and depending on what egg is
fertilized and thus what embryo is then
developed you have a chance that you can
have a defect or you might not have a
defect at all with mitochondria
inherited diseases there's in fact a
threshold of defects at Carriker that
you have the inheritance of far more
than just two or three mitochondria you
have the inheritance of several
mitochondria and what we can see now are
situations in which let's say you have
three different eggs and I'm not going
to show the nuclear DNA because that's
not what we're interested right now you
might have one egg that has three of the
mitochondria that have the defect so in
pink another one just has one and
another one has two
let's say for the sake of simplicity all
of the other mitochondria I will use one
color to denote them let's do purple so
here we have another three another three
and that's for the sake of argument have
another three now if you compare these
three different eggs what you'll see is
that in this case 50% of the
mitochondria that that egg has are
defective right in this case we're down
to 25% are defective 1 pink 2 3 purple
and in this case we see that 40% are
defective what is observed is that
typically with many mitochondrial
diseases if you're in the range of 25%
to 40% being defective you still have
enough normal mitochondria to generate
enough ATP so quite often these
individuals are normal or healthy in
this case what we might have is a
situation where 50% or in fact what's
often the case 50% to 60% of
mitochondria having the defect can often
result in a disease presentation
so what this means is that you can have
siblings in the same family you might
have one sibling where the egg was
fertilized where the egg that was
fertilized had 25% of the mitochondria
carrying the defect while another egg
was fertilized for different sibling
that had 50% or more
this individual appear will show the
disease phenotype while this individual
will be entirely healthy and so this is
one of the remarkable observations with
mitochondrial disease is that even
within the same family even with
siblings you can see variations in
whether or not the disease is seen is
presented or not so that one way of
thinking about it is that there is a
threshold if you will of the
mitochondrial mutation that must be
present for the disease to display
itself so that interestingly enough you
may not have realised this but for every
egg that is fertilized it's a little bit
of sort of a one-armed bandit where you
pull the lever three things come up and
in some cases unfortunately if three
defects come up or a high enough
percentage of mitochondria are defective
you cross the threshold for disease so
this is a very different way of thinking
about how disease might be inherited not
through the nuclear genome but through
the mitochondrial genome
you
[Music]